when you're working cable news you're
responsible not just for your own
behavior but the behavior of your
producers if one of them does something
wrong you've got to answer for you've
got to explain how the work environment
you created made this sin possible and
we're not sure we're on board with this
standard it seems a little broad but we
don't make the rules here cnn makes the
rules here this is the rule they made
and everyone in the tv business acts
like it's federal law
given that it was interesting to see one
of cnn senior producers arrested for
child molestation recently john griffin
is 44 he's been for years a prominent
member of the staff over at cnn last
week he was arrested by authorities in
vermont for having sex with children
now
typically you read all the ugly details
on tv but they're too ugly so we're
going to spare you them suffice it to
say
if these details are true then this guy
is awful and deserves to spend the rest
of his life in prison we're not the jury
here but the charges are very serious
in the meantime here's our question what
kind of diseased work environment at cnn
produced an accused child molester
now that's an obvious question it's
exactly the question cnn would ask of us
for example
but somehow cnn's tireless media critics
the eunuch and his bug-eyed accomplice
have not said a word about it which is
weird
now it's been reported that griffin
worked for a guy called john avon if you
watch cnn you may see avalon
occasionally he's the filling guy he's
the guy they call when the adults are on
vacation he shows up and tells you how
scary cuanon is
so that's the john avon you see on tv
but what's happening behind the scenes
did john avalon know that his producer
was molesting children is he for that is
he against it does he believe that the
moral tone he set at work played any
role in these alleged crimes against
minors
now we called cnn for answers yesterday
they wouldn't tell us
nor has avalon issued any kind of
statement about it including on twitter
where he lives pretty much all day
it's pretty weird behavior for a quote
journalist not adding facts to a story
you're involved in
we are journalists we would like some
more facts in this story and hopefully
we'll get them